[Music]
[Applause]
longtime NFL quarterback Chase Daniel
joining us from the quarterback capital
of the world that's Del Mar Drew Brees
Matthew Stafford Carson Palmer anybody
else who lives in Del Mar Chase
I'm sure there's a little bit more here
but uh you know Steve Mariucci is down
down the block from us too so it's a
it's a nice place to be right now it's
72 and sunny every single day so I can't
beat it all right help me understand
this uh first of all you're in between
co uh jobs right now so how does that
work that you wait for a call or can you
work out for a team
what's the process um yeah I mean listen
I'm I'm uh you know just finished 14
years going on 15 and uh to be
completely honest with you right now I'm
pretty I'm pretty good right now just uh
hanging out with the kids being a dad
not having to go to training camp sleep
in the dorms have a 15-hour a day
schedule
um but I think I'm past the part in my
career where I gotta work out for
someone uh played really well last year
in the preseason and uh yeah I'm just
just waiting for an opportunity and if
it doesn't come then uh you know we'll
see what else happens but I'm just
excited to to continue uh to talk NFL
football and college football and you
know I did some broadcasting stuff last
year so that was that was fun but yeah
it's just uh it's just a wait and see
game right now there's got to be some
injuries that happen I'm sure at what
point in your career do you Embrace
being a backup quarterback that you you
have to buy into that role and that can
be difficult because you know when you
got came out of Missouri you probably
thought I you know I want to be a
starting quarterback
yeah there's no doubt I mean that's
that's something I've wrestled with my
entire career
um and I told myself
um from an early age uh in this league
especially when I was learning behind
Drew uh in New Orleans was that Hey
listen I'm gonna play as long as as I
can as long as they want me to like get
me off the train because the train just
keeps moving everyone gets off
but the one thing that I told myself was
if I'm playing and I'm just okay being a
backup then I'm never gonna play anymore
so I would say even last year like you
have that itch it's just like that's
that's maybe me that's maybe how it was
raised that's maybe how I was brought up
but
um I think in this league to make it you
know 14 years which is a blessing like
thank God for that
um it's you have to have that mentality
of every single day you walk into the
building every single day you go out
into the football field practice field
preseason games are huge I mean I I
treat the preseason games even in year
14 like their playoff games because
that's how you get the film out that's
how you get the film out to all 31 other
teams and you're constantly competing so
I'm still at that phase right now like I
I love to compete I've never once really
phoned it in like hey I'm just okay
being a backup because the second you do
that guess what the third string or the
guy in college or there there's always
um you know someone behind you that
wants to take your job and I've never
really done that before I've never
looked behind me I've always looked in
front of me I've always tried to push
the starter
um for some playing time and and you
know for me it's sort of like it's a
weird situation like not a lot of
injuries right in 14 years like that's
sort of how backups get on the field not
a lot of injuries have happened I
haven't really gotten a ton of chances
uh and when I had them uh in the middle
of my career I thought I played pretty
well what is your favorite memory
yeah
oh my gosh wow I mean you're 14 years in
the league I mean honestly if I could go
back and do it I mean this is the easy
one to say but in 09 I was a rookie I
was a third train quarterback behind
Drew
uh and um Mark Burnell uh which is a
blast from the past
um so winning a Super Bowl with those
guys my rookie year I mean it it's
obviously the tops but like
I thought it was so easy like I'm like
after we won I'm like oh my gosh like we
started 13-0 if you remember that year
and then lost three straight and then
went on a tear in the playoffs Garrett
Hartley kicked us
um yeah you know to the to the to the
Super Bowl and against Minnesota but I
was just like I remember that off season
I was like this is so easy and then put
in perspective 14 years later I've been
on it's just it's unbelievable because
I've been on some of the worst playoff
losses of all time you look at even last
year right it's the the highest comeback
in the NFL history we were on the
Chargers we lost that game it was the
most you know when you look at the
Minnesota miracle I was on the other
sideline for that I was with the Saints
okay I mean you go on and on the Andrew
Luck Kansas City Chiefs game when he
fumbled we were up 35 to seven at
halftime 28 point come back they beat us
that's the fumble him reaching over the
game if you guys remember so it's been a
tough road because you really just look
back back on those years and you realize
man there's actually like a good bit of
luck involved and the ball has to bounce
your way you have to get certain calls
um from ref so it's been it's been quite
a run I mean there's there's some really
good stories stored up in this memory of
mine he's uh Chase Daniel he's a free
agent quarterback how many teams have
you played for
sticks I think had two stints with the
Saints so we'll say six uh do you have
jerseys of all the teams
I do yeah yeah we have um we just built
the house out here
um a couple years ago and uh you know we
have a we have a little bitty space that
my wife said I could put some jerseys up
obviously like this is my office you
don't see any jerseys in this office
right but we have a game room and I'm
telling you it's like how are we gonna
fit like six jerseys in this small like
but we made it work
um I have a ton of uh jerseys uh from
other guys throughout the league in my
garage so that's what I was relegated to
my garage as as the man gave you were
with the Chargers last year your
reaction to Justin Herbert getting that
contract yesterday I mean listen it is
it's awesome because uh yeah and I I
sent out a tweet yesterday a video
yesterday of just how proud I was of him
because it's hard to understand
obviously if you're not in in the room
but everyone knows about the physical
attributes what he's done the first
three years that's been well talked
about but you know what's interesting to
me is when I got there in 2021 he had
just won uh uh you know rookie of the
year after the 2020 season everyone
knows how that started with tyrock
Taylor's ribs getting punctured
um and so he got his opportunity man did
he ever roll with it probably one of the
if not the best rookie quarterback
Seasons numbers wise of all time
and so I'm looking at I'm like man I get
to work with the Rookie of the Year this
is awesome and the first day I come in
he's just saying hey like like I
followed your career like it from
Missouri like I know you were with Drew
like what did he do I knew he was Alex
Smith what did he do what could I learn
from other courts and I'm just like
that really hit me that just tells you a
little bit about who he is and what he
does and how he you know portrays this
game and how he takes the takes the game
so seriously and and um just like a like
a good old good old guy like yes sir no
sir super coachable
um uh the physical tools I mean you see
some throws in practice
um that is just like I mean there's just
not many people if anyone in the world
that can make these throws and and so it
was just it was an honor and a privilege
for those two years getting to back them
up we have a really tight relationship
and and you know he's still he's still
pretty young and uh you know he texts me
in the office and hey you know what are
you thinking about this and so yeah you
know it it's still a really good
relationship there but then you have
Austin Eckler who can't get paid
6.25 million dollars is the biggest
bargain in the National Football League
right here 40 touchdowns over the last
two years not only that but like what he
means to the locker room and he can he
couldn't get it I mean you know I love
the dude it was so fun I started
cracking up laughing when you said the
Derrick Henry stat we made the same
amount of money and I'm like hey Mama
I'm like oh that's cool but like man
like what like what is wrong with the
running back position and it's just it
just goes to show you that NFL
franchises I mean honestly they just
don't they don't value the position like
they used to I mean look at the Chiefs
last year they had a couple decent
receivers a seventh round running back
and they won a Super Bowl because they
have a really good quarterback and and
the Run game is ah okay you know and you
can find a good running back out there
like a really good running back for
three to four million dollars and build
your build yourself everywhere with with
the left tackle salaries going up you
saw Solomon Thomas today I mean every
everyone it's insane and then you got to
pay the defensive ends I mean the
charges have three or four guys over 30
million dollars on cap hits this year
here
um so there's just teams just don't put
it in the budget and I just I just don't
know if there's a way back from it I
mean I don't know what you can do to say
Hey listen unless all 32 starters say
I'm not showing up next year
um until we figure out a site agreement
with the with the NFL PA because I was
on the NFL PA side and we've talked
about it at least like how and it's just
like other than punter
and Long Snapper it comes in at running
back as the least amount of growth and
value since like two or three CPAs ago
it's insane but Chase if I what if I
suggested this we allowed running backs
to come out
after their sophomore year in college or
you could sign your running backs got
three-year contracts
when they came into the league if you're
a first round draft pick it's a
three-year contract
what do you think I mean the Shelf the
shelf life still on running backs is one
contract and and and you're going to get
to in a second but it's very rarely you
get to a second and like impossible you
get to a third so that that shortens
their career by instead of four-year
contract so you have three or five year
contract you know with first round
running backs but to me it just doesn't
make I just I don't think that helps
because at the end of the day teams are
going to Value what they value you are
worth what a team is willing to pay and
that's that's your value at the end of
the day so at the end of the day like if
teams don't Pony up and if major name
running backs Nick Chubbs saquon Barkley
Austin Eckler Tony Pollard everyone in
the Derrick Henry if they don't come
together I know they had a zoom and
that's great no that's not gonna that's
not gonna make change that's not gonna
make change
um it starts with the NFL and the flpa
and the owners are laughing to the bank
with this because they get really good
value at one or two year deal with not a
lot of guarantees well but look at
Melvin Gordon because of what he was
asking for Austin Eckler was able to
come in and take his job and yeah I mean
this is it's it's like uh you're eating
your own
I mean that's that's the biggest problem
we've dealt with in the nflpa in general
is is with these rise in rookie
contracts is okay that's great you're
Rising uh and rookie contracts but these
middle level Guys these four or five six
year guys that are just as good as these
rookies they're making a million and a
half a million two or whatever it is
league minimum these rookies are making
you know six fifty seven hundred
thousand dollars that's that's almost
another player if you cut a guy ah this
Rookie's just not quite as good but you
look at this five-year guy he's too
expensive I mean that's how running
backs are and that's what teams are
saying we just need a guy who can carry
the ball 100 to 150 times and by the way
we're gonna split the carries up because
every you know it's a past Happy League
unless you're the Ravens or the Eagles
right and and those guys are are doing
just fine with it so it's it's it's an
interesting conundrum that that we're
facing that the running back Market is
facing in general but I think for the
good of the game you got to figure out
something before I let you go I think
there are four other quarterbacks in
history
who have more pass attempts in the
preseason than you is that right Paulie
yeah we did a deep dive of uh
to see Chase Daniel is an all-time
preseason guy he's got 500 career
attempts in the preseason quarterback
rating of 92.5 okay all right so hey do
you know so if there's ever a hall of
fame for preseason
500. we can try to do that I mean come
on guys okay who's who's in front of you
who are the four quarterbacks pre-season
pass attempts more than you
Brian Hoyer
nope
what you what what year that's crazy
more attempts than me I mean they got to
play a lot a long time yeah and they got
to be a backup
they're all retired
oh my gosh I don't know who are they all
right give them Paulie I got Billy volik
over 500 Luke McCown over 500 attempts
that's right Luke I was with them in New
Orleans of course he was there for four
years
who else Paulie sage rosenfels has 549
career attempts wow can anyone guess the
highest oh no okay here's what I have
going back 25 years the most pre-season
attempts of any quarterback give me a
hint
we have them on the show regularly
they're probably three Sean Salisbury
nope that would have been awesome though
he he lives 20 minutes from our studio
Ryan Leaf Chris Sims Dan orlowsky 591
career attempts
I mean dude that's amazing so I just
need 92 more attempts and then I have
the all-time record then we can start up
now the Hall of Fame backup quarterback
is that feeding the fire to call off
retirement
well I thought you said about retirement
but I mean if we're starting a
pre-season Hall of Fame and I have a
chance to be the number one pass attempt
guy I want to hear this conversation
Chase with your wife I want to know what
that said honey honey yeah come here she
has to take care of the three kids so I
don't know if that's gonna happen but I
bet I could get 92 in three games coach
let me play the whole game call it 35
times every game we got this you don't
need to play anyone else you don't need
to evaluate anyone else orlovsky's
getting nervous you know oh my God his
legacy Dan Orlowski huh that's crazy but
see he ran out of the end zone like he
has a play that we at least remember
Chase yeah I didn't do anything dumb I
mean I love the guy I love the guy but
man like that and the amount of grief he
still gets thanks but I'm glad I'm glad
I didn't do anything like that uh good
luck but uh whatever's coming next
whether you're an analyst or you get a
job there but uh good to talk to you
Hank thank you for having a good sense
consumer
all right guys appreciate y'all that's
Chase Daniel free agent quarterback won
a Super Bowl's first year with the
Saints he's fun thank you Tom you're
welcome right